check out gigi hadid getting playful and  flirty on the set of her new Tommy  Hilfiger fragrance campaign only ET has  your first look at the 21 year olds  nautical inspired shoot she's surrounded  by sailors and she looks stunning in  that oversized pea coat here she even  adds a captain's hat into the mix it's  just a really really great feeling it's  safe to say we're all aboard with Gigi  the new scent is called the girl and  Gigi tells ET that working with Tommy  was incredible quote he makes you feel  like family the second you meet him he's  really supportive and loyal I'm feeling  so overwhelmed with happiness and  excitement